It's an incredible honor to be here.
And I've met so many wonderful
people so far this week.
And one of the things
that I've been thinking about
is how, at the end of this week,
most of us are going to pack up our bags
and go home.
Going home is a luxury
that's not available to everyone.
I think top of mind for a lot of people
right now is the situation in Ukraine.
Over four million people
forced to flee not just their country,
but their home in six weeks.
And that's just one of the major human
migration events happening right now.
They may no longer be making headlines,
but people are still trying to flee Syria,
Afghanistan, Eritrea,
and the list goes on.
People are forced to flee their homes
for any number of reasons.
War, yes, of course,
but also gender-based violence,
politically sanctioned persecution,
and more and more due to climate change,
which estimates say could displace
150 million people in the coming years.
So if human migration
is both inevitable and growing,
what are we, as a global community,
doing to address it?
Typically,
people attempting to seek safety
in a country not their own
are forced to languish
in dangerous situations for decades,
attempting to navigate
the suffocating bureaucracy
used by different countries to determine
who gets to be resettled and where.
The United Nations is involved,
and every country has its own
immigration laws and restrictions.
And there are multiple interviews required
and onerous documentation requests.
Not to mention the difficulty
of shepherding your entire family
through this process
when you’ve been separated, traumatized
and have few resources at your disposal.
But here's the good news.
It doesn't have to be this way.
Because the same thing
that is holding people back
can be used to help
move them forward to safe refuge:
the rule of law.
The key is to get legal knowledge
into the hands of those who need it most
and give them a chance to use the law
to open pathways to safety
for themselves and their families.
Although there's an entire industry
built around humanitarian aid
and response to various crises,
that aid typically
does not include legal services.
Many people hire a smuggler
to take them across a sea or a desert
because they don't even know
that they qualify for a legal pathway.
Others may know that they qualify
but may not know how to navigate
the interviews and the paperwork.
That's why so many people
end up stuck in camps for decades.
They're in legal limbo.
In this scenario,
access to legal information
and legal services
is just as crucial as access
to food, clothing and shelter.
And that's where we at the International
Refugee Assistance Project, or IRAP,
come in.
First, IRAP utilizes technology
through a digital platform
to make these laws
and processes more accessible.
We give refugees access
to timely, accurate
and culturally relevant information
about their legal rights and options.
IRAP also provides direct legal services
both on the ground and remotely
in partnership with a trained network
of front line refugee-serving
organizations, pro-bono attorneys
and other trusted legal advocates.
And finally, as we walk
side by side with our clients,
through every step of these processes,
we're able to identify systemic issues
that we can use the law to address
and ultimately change for the better.
It's these individual cases
that illuminate opportunities
for broader systemic reform.
Let me give you a case example
so you can see what I mean.
Aaron and Miriam.
Not their real names.
We had to change them for safety reasons,
and you'll see why in a second.
Aaron and Miriam are brother and sister.
They were separated from their mother
when they were all forced to flee
from their home in Eritrea
when they were children.
The kids ended up
in a refugee camp in Sudan,
and their mother ended up in Germany.
And in today's dysfunctional system
of refugee resettlement,
this type of family separation
happens all the time.
And typically what would happen
is either that the kids spend
decades stuck in the camp
or that their mother would be forced
to hire a smuggler
to take them on a dangerous journey
across the Mediterranean
just so she could be with them again.
These are both terrible options.
But luckily for Aaron and Miriam,
some of the staff in the camp
have been trained by IRAP
to identify cases
eligible for family reunification,
which is one type of resettlement pathway.
So we filed the application to Germany.
So far so good.
Until the German government
denied the application
because Aaron and Miriam
didn't have passports,
which they couldn't get
because the Eritrean government considered
them to be traitors for fleeing.
So approaching the embassy
to get passports
would have put their lives
in even more danger.
IRAP flagged this
as a wrongful, systemic barrier,
fought the case in German court
on the family's behalf and won.
(Applause)
And I am so happy to tell you
that Aaron and Miriam were reunited
with their mother in Germany
in June of 2021.
(Applause)
This is a joyful story
of family reunification
that legal advocacy made possible.
But there's something else at play here
that I really want you to see.
And it involves one of my favorite words
in the English language:
precedent.
Yes, I am a legal nerd.
This is my favorite word, precedent.
By bringing the case in court,
IRAP began to establish a precedent
to ease the passport requirement,
not just for Aaron and Miriam,
but for thousands of other refugee
children in similar situations.
When legal service providers
walk side by side with our clients
through every step
of these immigration processes,
we're able to identify the obstacles
that are preventing people
from reaching safety.
Do that often enough,
and you start to see
patterns in the obstacles.
And when we find a pattern,
we can advocate to change
the underlying law
that's creating the obstacle
in the first place.
It's the patterns that allow us
to open pathways
to resettlement at scale.
This was all put to the test
in Afghanistan.
For the past 20 years,
thousands of Afghans have worked
in essential and lifesaving jobs
on behalf of the US government.
They've been interpreters,
truck drivers and computer scientists.
And because of their US affiliation,
the Taliban has spent those same 20 years
trying to track them down and kill them.
So all the way back in 2009, Congress,
in response to this very real threat,
created a special visa program
for Afghan allies of the United States.
The purpose of the visa was to provide
those whose lives were in imminent danger
with quick resettlement to the US.
But at IRAP,
we knew that this program was broken.
We knew this because we were helping
more than 1,000 Afghans
try to navigate this visa process,
and we began to see a pattern.
It was taking on average
more than four years
for the US government
to issue these "urgent" visas.
Which meant that our allies
and their families
were at risk of Taliban assassination
because the US couldn't stamp
their passports quickly enough.
So in response,
we gathered our knowledge
from all of these cases,
filed a class action lawsuit,
and in 2020, we won.
(Applause)
A court ordered the US government
to process these backlog applications
in a timely fashion,
treating our clients' cases
with the urgency
that the situation warranted.
Now, as you all well know,
the US withdrawal from Afghanistan
has created a whole new level of chaos.
But our model has allowed us
to continue utilizing technology
to get crucial llegal information
into the hands of our allies
who have not yet been able to flee.
We're still in court
and in the halls of Congress,
demanding their urgent
evacuation and protection.
And we're going to keep looking
for obstacles to take down
and using the law to empower refugees,
just like we always have,
because that is the best way
to get these folks to long-lasting safety.
(Applause)
The last thing I'll say is this.
When faced with the reality
that human movement is in fact inevitable,
countries have two choices.
They can build walls and prisons
and separate children from their parents,
or they can create fair
and transparent legal systems
that facilitate safe
and organized migration and resettlement.
Functional rights-based legal
systems help everybody.
But unfortunately,
there are those who find it
more advantageous to demonize migrants
and politicize refugee crises
than to make serious plans to address
global migration in a safe,
orderly and dignified way.
Through this work,
I have met so many people
who embody the traits that we praise
in entrepreneurs and thought leaders.
It takes tenacity, creativity and bravery
to get yourself and your family
to a new country
to begin your life over again.
In my opinion, countries
should be competing for refugees.
But at the very least,
everyone should have
a safe place to call home
and a safe way to get there.
I wish all of you a safe journey home.
And thank you.
(Applause and cheers)